the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
home foreclosures due to unpaid
mortgages are down significantly from
the height of the mortgage crisis in
2009 down 85 percent actually this is
based on new data from the Federal
Reserve which shows that there were
85,000 foreclosures throughout the
country during the last quarter of 2016
which is still a lot of people that are
out of their homes but to put it in
perspective
there were 550,000 foreclosures during
the first quarter of 2009 foreclosures
have not been this low since the Fed
started pushing its macroeconomic data
report in 2003 there's about a hundred
and 26 million
single-family residences in the u.s.
giving a foreclosure percentage of about
Oh point zero seven percent or basically
from every ten thousand homes that seven
people being foreclosed upon so why why
are we seeing such a drop in
foreclosures number one we've had a
generally stronger economy so aside from
specific policy regarding mortgage
foreclosures if you have a stronger
economy you're going to end up with
fewer people in situations where a bank
may even attempt a foreclosure but also
since the mortgage crisis we've also had
stricter rules in terms of who can get a
mortgage so you know you hear from the
right all the time oh well I mean
regulation it just just let businesses
do whatever they want to do it actually
makes a difference we're now seeing
drastically reduced foreclosures and of
course Trump and the Republicans want to
scale back some of those regulations and
I actually think that these home
foreclosure rates are a good indicator
on the economy because when we try to
measure the economy sometimes we go
after unemployment which really just
affects the poor mostly or we'll talk
about the stock market but that affects
the rich so this poor thing that I think
affects more of the working class and
the middle class and that's really the
heart of the economy I generally agree
with you at the same time with homes so
unaffordable in
major cities in cities the homeownership
and foreclosure rate may tell us less
about other the average person but
generally speaking you're right I mean
of course no indicator on the economy's
going to be perfect yes absolutely so
yeah it's very interesting but it's also
most interesting to me because we heard
so much about how it doesn't really
matter what regulations you put in
businesses are going to do what
businesses are going to do and if they
do something that's bad for consumers
over the long term they'll suffer and
bubble bubble now the reason we have
fewer foreclosures is because it's now
more difficult to get a mortgage now you
could make the case Pat that it should
be easier to get a mortgage it's a
problem that it's more difficult to get
a mortgage because a lot of the people
who are turned down never would end up
being foreclosed upon sure some of those
people would not but I still disagree
that if there's any indicator from a
recent economic crisis that it actually
does make sense to have sensible
government regulations it's been the
mortgage crisis and these foreclosure
numbers show that this is also such an
indicator on how the American Dream is
functioning because a lot of times
people think of the American Dream as
the ability to own your own home one day
and not have to be stuck spending money
on rent for so long so I think this is
very good news I agree with you let's
talk about Flint Michigan Flint Michigan
riddled with the water led water crisis
led in the water major scandal governor
of Michigan was involved all sorts of
corruption with regard to the reasons
why the water source was switched I mean
we cover this extensively that's not the
news the news is that there are
thousands of people who are at risk of
as we just talked about foreclosures who
are at risk of losing their homes
getting kicked out of their homes
because of unpaid water bills of course
this is lead tainted water that people
haven't paid for and I have such mixed
feelings about this because on the one
hand I am sort of a you go by you you
use the legal methods you go through
things properly which is you keep paying
the bill but you eventually would
hopefully have some kind of recourse
because the water has been completely
led tainted I would not be the type of
person who just stops paying my bill
because I would
logically know that that's going to
create bigger problems for me at the
same time I understand this it it's led
tainted water that you're dealing with
for months upon months year upon year in
in some of these situations you're going
to be paying for lead painted water that
you're being told that never mind
drinking at certain points it shouldn't
come into contact with your skin it is
all insane how this is now going to
potentially lead to thousands of people
losing their homes I think I run the
risk of sounding like a conservative in
making this point but I think it's
pretty sound I think you know if your
water bill was going to some private
company then there would be a lot better
means of communication and that they
would respond from a PR perspective and
realize we can't be charging people for
a product that they didn't pay for yeah
you see what I'm saying and because it's
run by the government they have a lot
more authority and they don't have to
worry about that PR now when you go to
the city and say well look at this this
is the this is bad PR for you they say
we need the cash I mean we just need the
money we're in a bind and we need the
money there's no alternative city you
can go to because you live in that city
presumably yeah so this is how would you
handle it would you print protest stop
paying your water bill if you were in
Flint Michigan I wouldn't just like you
I would not stop paying my water bill
because I I know that they would keep
coming and that would affect my credit
and everything else yeah but I would be
you know protesting probably in open
communication with the city as I'm sure
the entire city is doing as well you
know it's pretty outrageous I can't
believe they're charging people what's
going on and what has been going on in
Flint Michigan has been unconscionable
for a very long time and we've covered
the corruption aspect of it we've
covered the health aspect of it we've
covered the political aspects and and
why this water source was changed to
begin with and there's no silver lining
that I've been able to find why it
wasn't even a story for years on end and
yeah this problem went way back before
the public at large knew about it it's
it's insane and we at remember a few
weeks ago I think we had a caller from
Flint Michigan and they weren't calling
about the water but I remember we asked
them about the water and they said they
don't even know who to believe but
they're not drinking it for sure
yeah because they introduced themselves
by their name and where they were from
and of course their question didn't have
to do with the Flint water crisis but
when you say you're from Flint Michigan
the natural follow-up is to ask about
the
dates on that yep no doubt about it so
and we've been following the story and
we'll continue following it and 8,000
people at risk of losing their homes now
okay cats do cats like humans Pat owns a
cat Pat is vegan Pat has talked about
his hesitation about the concept of pets
because you're sort of enslaving in a
sense the animals but cats cat is free
to roam in and out
pat pat pat cat hats cat not cats Pat
Pat's cat uh can go in and out right
right but there's no cat door you have
to what the cat in a now yeah it's a
minor point but you know generally minor
yeah like the cat is able to go in and
out and that actually caused a lot of
blowback for me because apparently these
outdoor cats have a great effect on the
migratory bird popular yes they kill a
lot of birds so people were furious but
my cat does not how would you know
though because they bring they bring the
cat the cat brings birds back Oh got
presents and that happens super rarely
for me here have there's probably a ton
of other people that your cat is giving
gifts to that's the thing why would it
give a gift to anyone else besides the
owner I just feel like they would okay
dead this is not the story the story is
the following it's often held that cats
don't really seem to like people in the
way that dogs like people researchers at
Oregon State University offered 38 cats
a choice between food a toy an
interesting smell so like catnip for
example which they like the smell of and
attention from a human 37% of the cats
that there's four choices right 37% of
the cats preferred food to anything else
more than the 25 you would expect if the
results were totally random 11 percent
preferred toys and one cat was
preoccupied with the smell of catnip and
gerbils half of the cats preferred the
company of humans above all of the other
options so it tells us something that
maybe cats don't dislike or are not as
indifferent to humans as we might think
I love the story but I think there's a
bit of an inherent flaw here because the
cat realizes that the human can provide
them with food and toys later on so you
think that the cat has been conditioned
outside of its natural in
stinks to see humans as something good
and that the results are not really and
they're not it it's yet this is how
domesticated cats you have been
domesticated because I think it is
natural to them at some point I mean the
relationship between cats and humans
goes as far back as ancient Egypt does
it really oh yeah that is that longer
than dogs no I mean dogs have been
domesticated for like ten thousand years
as well right yeah I don't know for sure
honestly but uh yeah but I mean there's
obviously a different difference between
how humans relate to cats versus how
humans relate to dogs
all today but the dog will pretty much
listen to you at any given time but a
cat has selective hearing it seems so
you know in my personal experience if
the cat is feeling particularly
affectionate she may come up to me she
may want to sleep in the bed with me she
may if I'm going on a walk she may even
follow me that's how close we are
Wow but at other times she'll just
completely ignore me do you ever leash
the cat when you go for walks I have a
friend who takes it takes they're kind
of his cats but they live at his parents
house in western Massachusetts and he
takes them for walks with harnesses and
they see he claims they like it I don't
do that in part because there's no leash
law for cats but people are always
fascinated they must think that I'm such
a great owner that the cat loves me that
must should just follow me around the
neighborhood hey Ford the cat whisperer
yeah I can see the memes coming now okay
but so do the results of the study and
by the way 38 is the sample size which
we could argue is just a completely
bogus sample size to begin with let's
pretend that the results are valuable
does this do anything for you in terms
of your feelings about the concept of
having cats as pets well I've been
conflicted about it all along and of
course I got my cat before I went vegan
it's more of a family cat that it is my
own personal cat right um I think it
would bolster my position that it's okay
to have an outdoor cat and provided that
they're not killing too many of the
migratory bird popular that migratory
bird thing I mean I was shocked how many
people were curious to do any any
decision that you make is going
negative consequence absolutely
absolutely you thought about okay that
does it for this bonus show thanks
running the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]